qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe regarder où est
ce que je vous emmène on est dans une
chambre semi anéchoïque le nom est un
petit peu compliqué on est en fait j'ai
des xo marque à boulogne-billancourt et
on s'est dit avec dxomark maintien on a
envie de parler de batterie on a envie
de pareilles d'autonomie on a envie de
parler de charges on a envie de
démystifier un peu tout ça et on a envie
de vous expliquer comment ça marche
comment bien chargé qu'est ce qui
fonctionne qu est-ce qu il fonctionne
pas quel chargeur il faut prendre pour
charger est ce que le câble et le bon
est ce qu on peut switcher prendre
d'autres charger va tout vous expliquer
on est parti avec olivier vous présentez
olivier de quelques instants on a fait
le tour complet on abordait tous les
points je pense que c'est une vidéo très
complète qui va vous rendre service on
bien comprendre d'une comment fonctionne
la charge de votre smartphone qui vous
guidera vous faire des achats ultérieure
pour comprendre un petit peu ce qu'il
faut faire pas faire ce qu'il faut
prendre pas apprendre comment ça va
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêt on va
partir aujourd'hui découvrir la matrice
vos smartphones comprend comment et
marche c'est secret les points positifs
les points négatifs qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il faut pas faire et vous allez voir
c'est super intéressant
on est donc un style switcher dxomark on
vient de rejoindre olivier olivier qui
est le boss la partie du protocole de
test au niveau justement des batteries
de smartphones olivier ça va très bien
merci à toi je suis très heureux d'être
avec toi ça fait un petit moment qu'on
se parle avec olivier on s'est dit il
faut qu'on part il faut qu'on parle de
batterie de smartphones il faut qu'on
parle de tout protocole de test a vu le
jour il ya pas très longtemps justement
vous tester l'autonomie des smartphones
mais on a tous une notion de ce qu'est
notre mini pour le grand public sur toi
si quand l'autonomie est l'autonomie
d'un smartphone ça va dépendre
d'énormément d'éléments forcément le
premier élément qui rentre en ligne de
compte ça va être la taille de la
batterie qui est dans le téléphone mais
pas seulement on a par exemple mesurer
plusieurs mobiles qui avaient la même
taille des batteries qui arrivait à des
autonomies totalement différentes parmi
les mobiles qu'on a testé en 5 millions
pereire par exemple on constate d
autonomie entre 36 heures 30 et plus de
70 heures donc exactement donc sa
musique si j'achète une bonne
smartphones avec une batterie de 5 mai
méliand période marque 12h05 millions
père georges peut aller du simple au
double exactement exactement c'est un
petit peu comme si chez le garagiste on
disait cette voiture à 58 2 réservoirs
et bien c'est une information mais sa
tête pas savoir l'autonomie que tu peux
attendre avec ta voiture c'est pareil
pour les millions père de la batterie
ensuite ce qui joue forcément tu à
l'écran évidemment plus tu as de pixels
puis ça va consommer tu as également la
technologie du cpu moi c'est le
processeur exactement les générations
récentes sont avec des finesses de
gravure plus fine qui font que c'est
plus économe pas nécessairement on voit
beaucoup de marques ont dix un
processeur qui est gravée en 50
nanomètres en 5 nanomètres ça joue
réellement cette toute petite est de
taille qu'est ce que ça va venir
apporter en fait absolument mais en fait
plus le composant et petits fin que les
informations circulent rapidement - il a
besoin d'énergie pour opérer et puis
bien sûr il y a
l'intégration logicielle intégration
hardware film dans le bi vice et puis
les optimisations logiciels et tout ça
fait que avec une même batterie tu va
observer d autonomie qui n'ont rien à
voir
je veux qu'on se parle un peu de temps
de charge parce qu'un vrai disparités au
niveau au niveau de la charge il ya
certains smartphones qui vont se charger
plus vite d'autres un peu moins vite
qu'est ce que tu as récupéré toi comme
donner justement au travers de
l'expertisé les différentes est ce que
tu as fait alors jusqu'à présent dans
parmi les téléphones qu'on a mesuré les
meilleurs sons autour de 30 36 minutes
et les plus mauvaises dépasse 4 heures
donc effectivement il ya une grosse
grosse disparité dans l'expérience on se
parle pas de test de charge de 0 à
combien les chiffres que je te donne
c'est pour une charge complète et une
charge complète nous on considère chez
dick se marquent qu'une charge est finie
grant le chargeur arrêtent de consommer
dans la prise mais en fait on mesure
plusieurs choses on regarde la vitesse
jusqu'à 80% pourquoi parce que c'est la
plage pendant laquelle le chargeur est
bien efficace et la charge rapide au
delà de 80 % atteint les tensions
maximum de la batterie tu es obligé de
ralentir et on ce qui s'appelle le tri
quelques charges pour préserver c'est la
chimie là c'est pour préserver la
batterie on voit que les temps de charge
ralentir drastiquement par exemple un
téléphone peut très bien mettre trente
minutes pour recharger 80% et une heure
de plus pour faire les 20 derniers
pourcents voilà donc on mesure nous le 0
à 80 on regarde aussi en même temps à
quel moment le téléphone va afficher à
l'utilisateur que la charge est finie et
on regarde le moment où effectivement on
constate nous dans la prise de l'élève
que le téléphone a vraiment cessé de
charge et en fait je veux dire qu'il ya
une vraie différence entre ce que ton
smartphone affiche est ce qui se passe
dans les faits oui tout à fait donc
c'est des contraintes physiques des
contraintes chimiques détention il est
pas exactement à 100% on constate une
disparité de quelques pour cent à 8 9%
des fois des cas c'est principalement à
un moment où la charge est vraiment très
très longue pour préserver la batterie
toujours le fabricant est vraiment
obligé d'afficher ses 100 % parce que tu
es potentiellement déjà en termes de
tension à la bonne tension parce que
cette tension ne dépend aussi de la
chaleur et donc comme la batterie
s'échauffe et peut-être qu'il n'a pas le
choix sa batterie lui dit je suis chargé
et ralentit et en fait ça commence à
baisser en température et la tension
suite aux nouveaux donc il peut remettre
ça veut dire qu'en fait si je regarde on
sait qu'on sache moment où je rentrais à
changer étincelant 0% je le branche
qu'est ce qui se passe là il va changer
très vite ou pas absolument si on y va
exactement parfois sur les plus gros
chargeurs c'est seulement quelques
minutes tu va atteindre les fameux 65
watts 67 watts qui sont annoncés ça peut
être deux trois quatre minutes où ça
valait vraiment très vite et puis par
paliers ça va progressivement descendre
toujours pour respecter des températures
de choses la sécurité de la batterie est
à 80% l'un tu t'approches de la tension
maximum de la batterie était vraiment
obligé d'y aller mollo mollo pour ne pas
les endommager donc ça veut dire qu'en
fabriquant de 10 par exemple j'aime
ressentir 65 voitures chargées en tout
100 watts et compagnie enfin je n'ai pas
à voir ce nombre de watts disponible en
permanence j'ai juste sur un petit
moment absolument absolument j'ai testé
le 120 watts je suis même pas sûr qu'il
a atteint 120 watts pendant une minute
complète d'accord vittini recharger sans
tomber pourcentage de confiance en votre
âme et je veux dire des conneries là
mais tu avais une minute à 120 watts et
ça te suffira de passer de 15 à 20% de
batterie en une mêlée tous d'accord ok
bon c'est déjà pas mal d'accord au
niveau de mon temps le saas et ça
[Musique]
en fait je me disais que vous quand vous
tester un smartphone typiquement tu vas
pas forcément chargé de 0 à 100% a aussi
ce qu'on appelle les plus boost fasse un
truc assez intéressante il ya le
rebrancher durant la journée comment ça
se passe en fait alors quand tu es un
utilisateur de toute façon tu attends
pas que ton téléphone s'éteignent pour
le charger est en stress monte un stress
donc pour mesurer l'expérience client
j'ai ce temps de charge de 0 à 100 c'est
obligé il faut la voir mais on va aussi
aller tester des rapides boost de cinq
minutes de charge à différents états de
la batterie quand l'interface affiche 20
% 40 % 60 % 80 % je vais aller mesurer
en cinq minutes combien je récupère et
je vais qualifier ça en terme
d'autonomie en cinq minutes de charge
combien je récupère l'autonomie doit
aussi j'observe une grande disparité
avec les plus petits blocs chargeurs qui
vont en cinq minutes d'offrir une heure
d'autonomie supplémentaires et les
énormes blocs chargeurs qui en 5 min
peuvent faire récupérer jusqu'à 7 heures
d'autonomie d'accord mais ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que si je prends un
bloc de charge 65 watts en cinq minutes
de charge je vais gagner beaucoup plus
d'autonomie qu'aussi g en 15 mois très
clairement c'est ça l'idée absolument
tout à fait c'est ça exactement vous
êtes autonomie que tu récupères c'est un
put de facteurs ta vitesse de charge
donc 65 watts vont se faire avec des
récupérer davantage d'autonomie mais
également aussi l'efficacité de ton
téléphone parce que l'autonomie
effectivement on a vu tout à l'heure
entre les milliers en paire eur tu ça se
traduit pas tout à fait en autonomie
donc si le mobile est bien efficace cinq
minutes de charge vont te donner une
capacité est cette capacité va se
traduire en autonomie grâce à
l'efficacité de ton téléphone ok j'ai
compris alors justement puisqu'on parle
l'efficacité et une autre vidéo qui va
arriver là arrive pas tout il ne va pas
tarder à arriver on va pas d'autres
protocoles de test aussi de comprendre
comment marchent les protocoles de test
au niveau batterie c'est un ol technique
et vous allez voir c'est pas très
compliqué parce que tu parles
d'efficacité l'efficacité au niveau de
la charge ça vous parle pas forcément
mais vous allez voir un tout qui élit
prêts intéressants on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours sur youtube donc ce que
vous faites cliquez sur le bouton rouge
juste en bas vous abonner les cloches
factiva cloches ont sonné la cloche
comme ça vous serez tous quand la
prochaine vidéo arrivera et on vous
parle justement de protocole de test
pour comprendre comment on vit à tester
et notamment cette notion d'efficacité
et alors il ya un autre élément qui perd
importants ont tu me parlais ce qu'on
appelle la consommation résidus et oui
alors c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué à expliquer mais lorsque tu as
charges définis tu as toujours ton
smartphone qui est accroché au chargeur
le chargeur qui est toujours un apprises
et bien on constate qu'effectivement il
ya une consommation qu'on appelle la
consommation résiduelles on va plus loin
on débranche le smartphone est bien
juste pour comprendre ouais quand ton
smartphone est chargé sur le secteur il
affiche 100% voilà lui il va continuer à
consommer en fait oui juste le fait que
le chargeur soit branché dans la prison
que le smartphone soit accroché aux
chargeurs sa console à console et ça
consomme de pas beaucoup c'est de
l'ordre de 200 à 400 glee watts donc
quand tu sais que le kilowattheure est à
peu près à 10 centimes je crois c'est
pas non plus énorme d'emilie watts quand
tu débranches le smartphone tu passes à
des ordres de grandeur entre 20 et 90
mille boîtes qui est très peu mais à
nouveau mettons qu'on a une consommation
de 70 militants résiduelles situe
multiplie par le nombre d'heures dans
une journée où dans une année qui
multiplie par le nombre de chargeurs
qu'ils existent dans le monde alors
selon les estimations entre quatre et
six milliards d'utilisateurs de mobiles
je sais pas combien peut-être charger
moi j'en ai eu au minimum 2 donc disons
10 milliards de chargeur branché et bien
on arrive à la production d'une centrale
nucléaire rien que le fait on les sent
son chargeur branché dans la prison
c'est ça donc j'ai une centrale
nucléaire à l'échelle du monde entier
absolument c'est un coût relativement
énorme donc ça veut dire que je dois
bien évidemment le débrancher pour ne
pas consommer mais ça veut dire que par
exemple quand je laisse mon téléphone
chargé durant toute la nuit je viens
consommer enterrement dans ce camp chine
affiche 100% on est nombreux on est
nombreux des redoublements vous en bas
pour commencer je pense qu'on le fait
très très nombreux à le faire le soir on
se couche on le branche et quand on sait
le matin on les branches première partie
que ça c'est pas mauvais alors c'est pas
bon mais à certains fabricants qui peine
s'en rend compte qu'ils ont des
algorithmes propriétaires qui viennent
un petit peu détecté à prendre tes
habitudes connaissent leur de ton aide
et qui vont donc ne pas consommer pour
finir la charge et optimiser ses
consommations néanmoins même si optimise
la charge le fait d'être branché sa
confiance la console typiquement asus il
le fait c'est en regardant d'un point de
vue logiciel te lis que ce soit sur leur
gamme de gaming où que ce soit sur leur
ordre une folle il te dit neil
évidemment tu peux me réglez diarra les
cuves a chargé deux heures avant ton
réveil on va venir optimiser sa mais
même si jamais lui il se divise en trois
classes moment-là raté ça concerne quand
même c'est exactement ça le simple fait
d'avoir déjà le chargeur dans le mur ça
consomme ces algorithmes vont quand même
maximiser surtout la durabilité de table
intrigue le fait d'être à 100% et de
maintenir à 100% c'est ça qui tape un
peu dans la batterie c'est pour ça
qu'ils optimisent en essayant de viser
les 100% au moment du réveil est pas le
laisser trop longtemps à 100% mais ça
consomme ça et c'est ce que ça endommage
la batterie à terme tu vois le swing
sauvegarde par exemple aller le matin je
me lève je le branche je fais mon petit
déj prend une douche on fait ce qu'on
veut ça vous regarde chacun à sa routine
du matin honteux comme on veut mais on
sent l'arrière ça dure une demi-heure 30
minutes 40 minutes est ce que c'est ça
qu'il faut faire tous que ceux d'hier le
soir je le branche gens lèvent le matin
est ce que c'est ce qui permettra aux
smartphones d'aller plus haut parce
qu'on pense effectivement consommation
électrique c'est un fait mais ça c'est
sûr l'addition en fait mais le fait
d'emmener le smartphone plus loin dans
le temps est ce que le fait de laisser
charger toute une nuit entière ça va pas
réduire durée de la batterie tu as tout
à fait raison il a tout à fait raison
c'est exactement ça c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les charges sont très
lentes au delà des 80 % c'est que sur la
fin on peut pas aller trop fort ça abîme
un peu la batterie complet donc qu'une
propose de charger 30-40 minutes le
matin c'est ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
faut faire ok on fait comme ça les i
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
on est seize nouvelles pièces on a un
robot on a un dossier de ce qu'on va
toujours olivier jeu toujours là on est
très contents vous êtes la droite et
dorian gray c'est bien bravo continue
d'ailleurs laissé moi je les pousse
alors moi j'aurais comparé les blocs de
charge parce que c'est l'homme de
charges c'est intéressant mais quand on
regarde un peu ce musée des
constructeurs on voit qu'il ya des blocs
de charges car soit on vendait du ce en
quoi tu avances et il ya quand même
quelques quelques temps ça fait 10 25
watts on a dû 65 watts on a dû 33 watts
on a du sens mouse qu'on comprend c'est
plus en a et mieux c'est en tout cas
c'est ce qui semble être le gîte est ce
que c'est vrai plus y'en a mieux c'est
alors ce sera vrai pour ton mobile sur
ton mobile tu mets un 33 watts ça va
charger moins vite que si tu mets le 65
watts compatible j'insiste sur
compatible parce que on voit faire la
démo là tout de suite de plus en plus
les protocoles de charge de sont devenus
propriétaires propriétaire ça veut dire
quoi qu'il ya un protocole de
communication entre le téléphone le
cordon usb et à hisser le câble
également est reconnu par ton smartphone
et le bloc de charger ils se connaissent
ils savent se parlaient et bien sûr à
des vitesses de charge à 65 watts il ya
tout un équilibre à trouver pour éviter
l'échauffement de la batterie pour
éviter les potentiels risques et des
potentiels dommages et donc c'est qu'on
pourra voir et bien soit tu fatigues ta
batterie et du réduit sa durée de vie
comptez ça c'est le meilleur des cas si
le pot de colle et mal fait six tués
chauffe ta batterie trop français tu te
lèves attend ça tu ne fais pas ton char
jean propriétaire non ça tu peux le
faire avec un chargeur qui n'a
strictement rien à voir et qui n'est pas
du tout optimisé oui sauf que sauf que
dans ces cas là le mobile il a quand
même une protection même s'il va pas
reconnaître le blog charger et yvain
imposer une charge très douces des
karaokés voilà donc normalement on
essaye fut le seul souci qui peut
arriver avec un chargeur bizarre lambda
c'est le bloc charger lui même temps que
ça veut dire que si par exemple j'ai un
smartphone qui acceptent de leur
chargement de 100 watts mais qui je le
mien 65 - qu'est-ce qui va se passer est
bien là encore plusieurs possibilités
c'est une charge 25 poite qui est normé
par exemple par le usb power délivré
dans ce cas là le blog charger ci
supporte ce même protocole va pouvoir
lui donner du 25 watts il est totalement
propriétaire et qu'il est sur un
protocole du fabricant et en dehors de
la norme usb un délit et bien non il va
charger indice 15 watts maximum ok
sanofi si l'epa pouvant délivrer le 6 et
lui même il est à 25 points pas énorme
elle est là aucune chance de marcher à
25 watts avec un parfait non aux caisses
alors souvent fait ce que tu me dis
c'est qu'il faut un smartphone il faut
le câble du fabricant et il faut le
chargeur du fabricant csq est plus
optimiste c'est exactement ça et
d'ailleurs je peux même te le trouver si
tu veux on fait l'exercice alors la démo
j'ai ici donc un mobile que tu reconnais
certainement one place et y exactement
avec son cordon usb et son blog charger
one place également compatible j'ai
lancé la charge et à 5 à 10 minutes il
est resté quelques minutes à 65 watts tu
vois qui fait des paliers qui commence à
ralentir un petit peu sa charge pourquoi
c'est pour éviter que la batterie
chauffe mais on est ici encore un peu
plus de 40 watts on est exactement 1
43.51 soit son billet en fait il a
chargé au tac aux depuis le départ et
puis là il est exactement fait ça
exactement ok donc là à l'écran si je
regarde tu vois on a déjà quelques
minutes j'en récupère et 38% alors je
vais faire un test très simple donc
j'enlève le cordon usb et je le remplace
par un autre cordon usb pareil cellule
type cc la même connectique donc je le
mets dans le chargeur one club et ça
c'est quelque part une identification de
la marque ouvre on s'en fiche un truc un
peu ce temps là le usb type 7 août ips
et cela vient de charge alors ils se
téléphonent va se remettre en charge il
va essayer de reconnaître le cordon usb
il va essayer de reconnaître le chargeur
et il va recommencer sa charge et bien
tu vois qu'il était au delà de 40 watts
oui hélas il est scotché il est assez
what lies dont elle ok voilà 30 watts et
ont signé ça en fait alors comment ça se
fait c'est que le cordon lui-même est
reconnu par le smartphone cr qu'il ya un
élément il ya une électronique dans le
cordon du wan pluzz qui s'authentifie et
qui dit je suis bien le cordon one plus
c'est bon ok peut envoyer des en paires
supplémentaires je vais pas fondre
d'accord c'est juste ça en fait c'est
juste ça d'accord et la différence au
niveau du câble à l'intérieur qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est que c'est un cadre
qui va être un peu plus apte à plus gros
diamant exactement ça c'est exactement
ça ok et alors si on change le chargeur
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors là j'ai
pris un blog charger de mammouth 1 120
watts qui vient de chez qui ça c'est au
pot non c'est annoncé xiaomi session
donc chomis est une marque concurrente
de one place ils ont également développé
leurs charges propriétaire donc là j'ai
un chargeur 120 watts que je vais
brancher un téléphone compatible 65
watts mais à nouveau ils vont pas se
reconnaître le protocole va pas se
mettre en place entre les deux et on
devrait constater les mêmes dit votre
charge avec un maximum de 28 watts
lorgne à 41% sur ce qu'on aurait tout à
l'heure voilà il donc là est donc là en
comme tout à l'heure on reste bloqué à
27 watts et on voit que même si le bloc
charger supporter 120 watts même si le
mobile supporte 65 watts ils n'arrivent
pas à se mettre d'accord ils n'auraient
pas à discuter et on reste sur des
charges relativement lente ouais mais
pour autant il est bien sûr pour autant
il se charge donc qui bars par défaut
sur des modes scène ils vont pas
s'abîmer l'un l'autre et ils vont juste
me prendre plus de temps à charger le
téléphone mais ça c'est un système de
protection recettes qui est d'ailleurs
oui c'est un système de protection parce
que les niveaux de charge négocier je
dirais entre le smartphone et le bloc
chargeurs sont différents il faut que le
chargeur soient authentifiés il faut
qu'ils soient capables de donner ce qui
est attendu par le smartphone donc les
charges rapide on parle en watts mais en
fait c'est une multiplication de volts
et dans père il ya des mobiles qui vont
charger à 5 volts quatre ans perd ça te
fait du 20 watts il ya des gens qui
supportent 9 volts trois ans perd ça te
fait du 18 et en fait la combinaison 1
120 watts la combinaison à 65 watts peut
changer 15 watts 3 ans perd tout ça peut
changer et donc il faut absolument
qu'ils arrivent à se mettre d'accord et
qui supporte exactement le bon niveau
attendu par le smartphone est donc là si
je regarde et bien mon 120 watts avec
mon mobile 65 watts il reste bloqué à 20
watts de charges 19 voilà ils vont pas
aller apporter l'expérience optimum qui
est proposée par le one love et yves ça
veut dire que si par exemple je me
prendre un bloc de charge dans une
province qui est beaucoup aujourd'hui de
smartphones qui se rendent sans bloc de
chasse et que je prendrais bloc de
charges dans le commerce qui n'est pas
celle du constructeur parce que d'un peu
moins cher avec ça m'arrange il faut
vraiment je tombais sur deux certifiés
pour éviter d'avoir des déconvenues à
oui il faut essayer de connaître quelles
soient un peu les caractéristiques de la
charge de son smartphone et essayer de
repérer c'est très compliqué honnêtement
moi dans mes protocole de thaci a peint
de chargeurs qui est inclus dans la
boîte je vais sur le site du fabricant
et je vais je prendre un chargeur
compatible certifié authentifié parce
que je sais que je mesurerai pas la
meilleure charge possible avec un
générique
[Musique]
tu as un téléphone derrière toi qui est
en train de regarder une vidéo vidéo
écoutez madame vous savez bien il
s'entraîne compagnie va alors l'or est
dans un endroit sympa une cage de
faraday juste pour resituer avait
contacté une fois de plus on note
regarder une vidéo un peu plus tard on
va visiter et comprendre ce qui se passe
il dit que sa marque comment on est
encore dans un endroit qui est un peu
particulier on est complètement les
journées de l'extérieur c'est ça en fait
la cage de faraday c'est une pièce qui
est sol compris fait de métal conducteur
et qui permet de s'isoler totalement des
ondes et des perturbations extérieures
donc ici qui est un collègue passe avec
sortie soit allumée ou quoi bon c'est
pas drôle c'est par n'en dit pas plus on
regarde ça pour la prochaine vidéo ah
bon et vous saurez tout piqué la cloche
et compagnie vous connaissez l'histoire
alors moi je voudrais qu'on parle un
petit peu des usages et des usages qui
console parce qu'un smartphone on
l'achète pour en faire des choses on
n'achète pas uniquement pour le regarder
bien du fond ils sont beaux et ça c'est
bien pour les achètent pour les utiliser
et des usagers consomment beaucoup il ya
des virages qui consomme pas beaucoup
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer un
petit peu quels sont les usages qui vont
beaucoup consommées en termes de battre
alors c'est très simple un flûte utilise
les capacités du smartphone pu te
sollicite je dis mon plus tu consommes
dans tous les cas l usage que nous on
mesure cedex marque celui qui est le
pire pour la batterie c'est la prise de
photos et de vidéos celle usage de la
caméra tient le capteur qui a lu métal
cpu gpu qui est en train de faire des
calculs sa toque des données même le gps
est allumée pour pouvoir géotaguer ta
photo quel écran bien sûr est allumée et
donc c'est vraiment le cas d' usage qui
est le plus consommateur de batterie on
constate d autonomie qui vont de trois
heures à 8 heures lorsque tu es en
continu en train de faire des photos
vidéos photos vidéos photos vidéos
selphy photos vidéos sons vidéos s'agit
exactement quand tu fais ce cas de tests
certains mobiles tu peux complètement
épuisé talent a pris en trois heures
s'il veut donc dire que si par exemple
moi je me dis je veux en faire un
shooting photo pour à les immortaliser
des vacances ou que je suis serein
événement par exemple c'est plein de
photos et bien c'est ce qui va consommer
plus et ça ça me paraît bien parce que
c'est vrai comme ça on ne dit pas que
c'est ce qui va concerner tous ses
smartphones les plus chauds pourtant
avait des trottoirs 1d x les modules
photos et les modules caméras qui les
verra à chauffer et puis bon bien sûr
tout ça c'est optimiser mais
effectivement oui tout est en train de
travailler tue stocke des données tuer
des calculs tu les combinés c'est
vraiment l' usage le plus gourmand juste
derrière tu as le gaming et me dit à
marie eugénie les arrières je suis à
l'écran allumé tu as le cpu et gpu qui
sont en train de faire des calculs d
affichage incroyable un peu comme la
caméra mais pas le module photo j lui
est un et donc ça consomme un peu moins
que les usages caméra a contrario qu
est-ce qui va consommer le moins à ce
que l'un team dit effectivement la
caméra le gaming et forcément les usages
qu'on va faire tout ce qu'on fait tous
les jours et qui consomme quasiment rien
du tout c'est certain tous les usages ou
l'écran est éteint ou allez forcément le
volume sonore il sait pas grand chose il
faut être écran est un conte mesure
c'est je n'ai pas grand chose c'est les
appels
voilà donc quand tu appelles l'écran est
éteint donc les appels mais ça pénalise
appels téléphoniques un peu ce soir
parce que si je fais un appel par
exemple par instagram paroisse a fait
compagnie la plupart du temps monde est
cruel mais c'est bien sûr sa console
bien sûr ok donc il vaut mieux utiliser
son bon vieil appareil téléphonique
voilà la sinne de l'opérateur pour faire
ton appel à l'ancienne le music freak à
un usage en mobilité forcément qu'il
boit tout le monde dans les transports
avec le quinze qui sont en musique
stream et sa pareille l'écran et 1,5 à
usage où l'on constate d autonomie qui
font plusieurs dizaines d'heures ça
consomme très peu et puis au milieu il
ya tous les autres usages la navigation
gps qui consomment pas mal aussi la
lecture de vidéos jeux vidéo streaming
vidéo les bacs bon même si ce n'est pas
sûr que ça existe encore beaucoup vient
de quelqu'un qui veut sur youtube
regardez par exemple tout de suite là
vous êtes en train de regarder cette
vidéo sur youtube sans votre smartphone
sa console wii donc c'est ça consomme
beaucoup pas carotte qui la consomment
beaucoup je dirais que les autonomies
constaté vont aller de 10 à 15 20 heures
d'accord ok y'a un flic est super
intéressant aussi c'est pour voir
beaucoup de constructeurs nous hanter
notamment dans l'entrée milieu de gamme
comme des fois pas nécessairement des
smartphones avec des grosses batteries
de 5 millions intérieur est pourtant là
qui vont avoir des
résolution full ace de plus d'autres
éventuels avoirs du wqs des plus et pour
autant il ya une variation au niveau de
l'autonomie comment ça se passe et
comment ça fonctionne alors plus tu as
de vxl à allumer l'idu consomment de la
batterie c'est pour ça qu'on constate
c'est certains fabricants malgré une
résolution condamne jeudi l'interface
utilisateur va être présentée par défaut
en full hd seulement d'acheter plus bien
sûr alors ce qu'on mesure nous c'est le
mode de l'utilisateur par défaut l'alma
de sortie de boîte est bien etc ou des
mobiles qui ont fait le choix de
n'afficher qu'une résolution full hd +
vont être un petit peu avantagé canton
complet de sa part des plantes est un
peu plus contre un où on va aller mettre
tout le monde sur un pied d'égalité et
comme ça on compare des pommes avec des
pommes et des torchons avec les
serviettes en face à venir et c'est ça
c'est super intéressant puisque tu me
dis alors j'ai pensé notamment un
smartphone de samsung se battent à ultra
c'est ça qui lui est vendu il faut poser
dans le commerce en étant en oublier
qu'elle dit plus et quand on louvre il
est en full hd + par exemple etc qui lui
permet d'offrir une autonomie moyenne
correcte d'accord parce que voilà ça
veut dire mais dans votre sens du code
de temps ça va être testée en fout là je
les vois la forêt plus aucun sens
alors on change de spots regarder où on
est on est pas mal c'est une chambre
semi ameco it ici absolument c'est celle
qui est utilisée par mes collègues qui
vont aller mesurer la qualité audio de
nos téléphones d'accord donc ici c'est
très bête c'est très amusé le son des
années qu il sait qu'il ya plus d'écho
en fait donc ta voix normalement tu
l'entends rebonds et 7 revient plusieurs
fois plusieurs trajets ainsi que des
noms qu'on va continuer à parler
d'autonomie je comprends l'autonomie au
niveau de la luminosité parce qu'on voit
effectivement que ce smartphone quand on
est entre le soleil qui fait super beau
et bien lui va venir pousser à fond
l'autonomie sera moindre que l'on se
rendait le soir dans la chambre en train
de boire un ptit drogue avant d'aller se
coucher avec son petit plein de vie mais
qu'est ce qui se passe mais ça marche
parce qu'on a des idées là-dessus de
chiffres l'autonomie comment les impacts
et j'ai fait des mesures bien évidemment
je te souviens je fais des tests en
général qui sont avec les réglages usine
par défaut par contre j'ai aussi le
capacité d'aller calibre et la
luminosité de l'écran et donc j'ai fait
le test j'ai mesuré un même smartphone à
différentes luminosité donc on parle en
it qui connaissait donc à 100 et 200
nits 300 nits qui sont des luminosités
que tous les téléphones portables
supporte et qui sont pas des luminosités
non plus incroyable donc le test était
de montrer une image est la même et de
mesurer l'autonomie j'ai pu mesurer que
des sur le même téléphone des
différences qui vont presque du simple
au double donc on était à une quinzaine
d'heures en autonomie à 300 nits une
vingtaine 1,25 à 200 nits en ligne ça me
claire pas beaucoup en été à 41 21
heures d'autonomie pour voir ailleurs
non on voit pas grand chose et écoute ce
site énorme c'est trop déjà ok ça leur
choix et 308 s'est pas non plus ça
suffit pas en plein soleil trousses en
émoi et a déjà son autonomie qui est
divisé par 2 juste pour afficher une
image n'est pas en train de faire des
photos ou de regarder une vidéo est
juste en train de regarder une image
donc l'impact sur les écrans après ça
dépend également bien sûr de la techno
d'écran et ça je peux faire ça sur
plusieurs écrans et on ne trouvera à peu
près toujours les mêmes résultats mais
de la console en tout cas va dépendre
aussi de la taille de l'écran du nombre
de pixels bien évidemment mais si je
fais le test sur un d'hiver et je vois
déjà que de passer de 300 nits 500
litres tu va multiplier son autonomie
par de décor donc ça veut dire que quand
j'ai un peu moins de lumière dans la
pièce exit l'autonomie commence à
baisser mieux vous baissez en fait me
guy minorité de nos smartphones et comme
ça je vais pouvoir prolonger la durée de
vie même s'il me reste quelque chose
comme 30% je vais vraiment pouvoir aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est évident ça
c'est génial c'est un premier pas qui
est super intéressant et un autre temps
qui est vachement cool on joue toujours
avec toi c'est la nuit si mon smartphone
je le mets pas en changer là bas si vous
le faites moi je ne cherche pas on l'a
dit pourquoi regarder la vidéo c'est à
vous la remettez vous comprendrez ça
veut dire que je le pose sur mon chez
moi j'ai le réflexe de l'état le maître
mot des livres des questions ondes c'est
mon truc je cours je fais comme ça mais
si je les peins parce qu'il constate
quand même que ce smartphone est bien
hyper haut niveau d'autonomie toute ma
batterie les plus basses pour autour
j'ai rien fait j'ai pas joué c'est dormi
enfin je veux dire j'ai rien fait quoi
ça baisse autant fait alors c'est
certainement un peu agaçant
effectivement ces casses pieds parce que
quand on ne sert pas du smartphone on
s'attend ce qu'ils consomment rien je
suis d'accord avec toi c'est un peu
frustrant mouscron mesure c'est pas en
heures pleines et c'est une bonne
pratique que tu as je trouve le mode
avion m mode avion c'est très très bien
comme ça tu coupes tout la radio et ça
fait justement partie des consommations
pendant la nuit le téléphone reste
accroché au réseau il continue d'écouter
les cellules et de communiquer soit sans
qu'il sache il fait plein d'autres
choses aussi il peut à ces moments là
allaient se connecter à des serveurs
pour savoir s'il ya des mises à jour
vers du nettoyage aussi un petit peu
dans ses mémoires et donc il fait c'est
une bête vivante en fait le smartphone
et quand tu n'utilises pas il fait quand
même plein de choses toujours voir
adopter nous ce qu'on a mesurée c'est
une mesure comprend aussi parce que
pendant la nuit c'est quand même très
décevant pour l'utilisateur final si
l'indicateur de batterie a perdu
quelques % plus une en perd plus on se
dit mince il fait n'importe quoi ce
qu'on a vu c'est que meilleur smartphone
arrive n'avoir qu'un pour cent qui tombe
pendant les huit heures d'une nuit alors
nous dans le gouffre est un seul % de
batteries dans nos tests il reste
accroché au réseau ils peuvent se
connecter ils font tout ce qu'on fait
quand on se met pas en mode avion rp
mode les plus mauvais il avait perdu 5
6% et ça c'est pas top le texte explique
cette différence entre le 1 % et ça
c'est pour ça qu'on se sont
principalement des optimisations
logiciel devient de plus en plus de
fabricants qui ont des modes nuit et ben
c'est pas très compliqué rires père
l'heure qu'il est qui vont se mettre
dans un mode restreint un mode du doubs
où ils cessent toute activité ils sont
pas en alerte sans cesse à récupérer tes
nouveaux mails à récupérer tes
notification des messageries et tout ça
il coûte ses activités en tâche de fond
est comme ça et ça leur permet de
n'avoir qu'une consommation très réduite
pendant la nuit et puis si tu fais rien
ben dans what's à ton facebook va
continuer à aller chercher toutes les
notices va continuer d'afficher tout ce
que tu reçois et c'est là où ça qu'on
soit d'accord un autre point c'est la
dernière partie des 20 derniers
pourcents j'ai l'impression on a parlé
tous les deux mais en fait lorsque tu
arrives à 20% est l'un des 60 à
smartphone il va donner % ils vont
descendre hyper vite et sur d'autres
smartphones tu dis ok c'est bon j'ai
l'impression que tu perds tu as
l'impression qu'en fait tu vas % s'est
pas réellement 2% eh bien tu as une
nouvelle fois complètement raison les
examens préparer la vidéo je n'ai pas
inventé merci c'est lui qui a raison
on le mesure en mesure de manière assez
fine est assez précise et on le prend
aussi en compte dans notre score final
parce que exactement comme tu dis ces
vingt derniers pourcents vrai ce sont
les 20 derniers pourcents qui coûte cher
pour l'utilisateur final on commence à
être en soi on commence un compte et les
% et à essayer de compter le temps qu'il
reste jusqu'à la protéger en charge on
commence à pas être à l'aise lorsque on
a mesuré c'est par rapport à l'autonomie
complète combien vous durée les 80
premiers pourcents et combien vont durer
vingt derniers tours et ses 20 derniers
pourcents on a toute une plage de
comportement des téléphones que nous
avons mesuré certains téléphones cette
durée des 20 derniers pourcents ne dure
en fait que 13 % du temps du test
complet et 13% c'est exactement le
comportement que tu expliquer où la
batterie tout à coup elle chute ça
arrive malheureusement généralement en
fin de soirée quand tu commences à être
en soeur est certain que tu vas pouvoir
appeler un taxi ou un chauffeur et tu te
situes tu aperçois que tout le reste de
la batterie tenait tout net on est
étonné dans tes usage tu fais pas plus
de trucs spécialement mais tout à coup
les pourcentages de la tripe tombe ça
c'est un peu des sceptiques comme
comportement de ton smartphone
al'inverse on a des fabricants qui vont
te rassurer on avait mesuré je crois
jusqu'à 28% sur 1 3% voilà sur les
internés % qu est-ce que mon smartphone
ce mois il n'affiche pas de 28% alors il
reste 28 % 8 il te met 20 % c'est toi
c'est quoi le truc sic en fait la partie
logicielle n'arrive pas vraiment à ce
qu'elle est avec ce qui reste dans la
batterie il ya des erreurs lecture
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a un écart qui est
c'est quand même énorme que ce soit
entre dans les deux extrêmes 28% on dit
qu'on est sur 20 % à 28 % cet ami
beaucoup beaucoup plus soit 13% si c'est
pas assez ouais alors tout ça ça ce
calibre par le fabricant sur la tension
de la batterie et cette tension ben ils
mesurent pas exactement la capacité pils
et c'est juste la tension tu sais à peu
près autant et il va graduée comme ça
son indicateur batterie les % après il
ya des disparités dans les ardeurs il ya
des choses qui font que c'est peut être
compliqué la température à nouveau peut
rentrer en compte c'est pour ça qu'on
fait nos tests nous dans un labo
température de bureaux et dans les 20
degrés mais c'est pas simple et puis
parfois il ya des parties arrivent ya
des gens qui pensent que toute façon qui
va mettre ton mobile en charge avant
qu'il soit 20 % et on si tu le mets en
charge avant d'être 1% pour que toi
utilisateurs tu vas jamais les vivre ces
vingt derniers pourcents pour
l'impression et voilà c'est le problème
c'est que quand on en a besoin et ben
ils trahissent ses 21 ans donc voilà
s'il ya des partis pris jeudi que sa
marque en tout cas ce qu'on considère
c'est que ces vingt derniers % s'ils
correspondent à beaucoup moins que 20 %
en série de victoires c'est pas bon dans
l'expérience utilisateur quand ça
t'arrive tu es très déçu mais d'un point
de vue global qui me donne les bons et
les mauvais élèves non pas pour les
stigmatiser introduit mais pour essayer
de comprendre un petit peu expliqué qu
est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui
fonctionne qu est-ce qui fonctionne pas
là on parle des mois dernier pour le bon
élève s'est alors les bons élèves j'ai
par exemple les iphone quand il affiche
20 % et bien il ya plus y a plus
beaucoup plus c'est celle iphone 12 pro
mac ce qui en fait pour lequel il reste
en fait 28% des coraux voilà c'est fait
après ça te rassure en fait tu trouves
que le comportement de téléphoner
saintes avant de ne pas te lâche pas et
tu peux même continue puisque tu
n'imagines et c'est donc tu arrives à
prix 1 - 2
mais c'est une blague donc ça ça
fonctionne bien côté peu déceptif alors
côté déceptif c'est un téléphone qu'on a
testé que je connais bien j'y ai
travaillé également un nico deparrois
rubin qui pour lequel les 22 derniers %
correspondent en fait seulement un trait
et demi pour cent comme on disait tout à
l'heure alors ce pas avoir eu 20 il a
une autonomie de fou donc finalement en
général tu arrives pas jusqu'au 20 %
mais quand ça t'arrive eh bien il faut
trouver un chargeur très vite parce que
c'est bien pour cent tel qu'affiché et
correspond pas du tout et on tombait
très très bien qu'en règle générale les
bons les bons élèves au niveau de l'eau
au niveau de l'autonomie on arrive à
identifier des modèles des smartphones
qui seront meilleures que d'autres et
d'autres qui fera moins bien on s'est
vraiment modèle d'un modèle mais ne
laissez pas le cas il marque s'il ya une
gamme bien évidemment souvent mais même
dans une même gamme il ya de tout il ya
de tout il ya de tout il ya des mobiles
très haut de gamme avec toutes les
dernières technologies qui vont un peu
souffrir en autonomie il ya un des
mobiles entrée de gamme qui ne vont pas
se battre sur la meilleure caméra vont
pas se battre sur le meilleur écran qui
du couvent proposer une autonomie
correcte nous ce qu'on peut noter c'est
que dans les premiers mobiles de nos
scores on a des mobiles assez équilibrée
au lancement de notre corps en numéro 2
on avait la meilleure autonomie parmi
tous les mobiles tester c'était le oui
co-favorite rend au numéro 3 on avait un
mobile qui avait une bonne autonomie et
une super charge il proposait en
autonomie modéré deux jours là donc plus
que correcte par contre il très chargé
en quelques trente minutes les 80% de
batteries donc en fait quoi de 30
minutes aux deux jours d'autonomie ne
sais pas et puis en quatrième on avait
le mobile le plus efficace de tout ce
qu'on a testé c'est l'iphone 12 promax
il a une autonomie correcte il a un
temps de charge correcte mais il est
très efficace parce qu'il arrive à
proposer toute cette expérience avec une
batterie beaucoup plus petit d'accord
que le reste des autres téléphones donc
à une vraie optimisation logiciel tout
et tu me
connaissent bien le chipset ce qu'ils
font ils connaissent bien le est celle
qu'ils font ils connaissent bien
il arrive à tout optimisé ok j'ai
compris et bien écoute pas mal voilà et
bien écoute c'est un plaisir c'est un
plaisir partagé vous savez tout est au
courant vous savez exactement ce qui se
passe qui est bon ce qui est pas bon on
commence à voir comment ça fonctionne à
l'intérieur de la twingo smart
d'ailleurs comment ça marche d'une façon
globale à l'intérieur de votre
smartphone c'est super intéressant
d'ailleurs vous dites moi vous embarque
dans les commentaires est ce qu'il ya
des choses que vous connaissiez déjà un
petit peu au niveau de l' usage de la
batterie au niveau de l'autonomie est ce
que vous découvrez tout est ce que vous
avez vous également des astuces à venir
partager les gros conseil et pour venir
permettre à tout un chacun est bien de
mieux utiliser son smartphone au
quotidien ma fille et moi tout ça bien
évidemment en bas on commentaires je
voulais dit on se retrouve très bientôt
chez dxomark ici à boulogne-billancourt
est évidemment faux youtube je sais pas
vous emmener sur vous pour que vous
pourriez venir tous mais non papa
organisent un bus sur youtube on va
venir faire un petit peu un tout parce
que je pense à super intéressant on
comprend comment est ce qu'on vient
tester un smartphone ici comment ça
fonctionne au niveau des protocoles de
test au niveau de la batterie de police
derrière il ya déjà des robots qui
travaillent qui sont en train de tester
en train de répliquer votre doigt donc
ils font que le vote doit il touche il
navigue sans aucune intervention
logiciel est assez intéressant on
regardera ça d'ici quelques temps d'ici
là je l'avais bien évidemment à vous
abonner à que la petite cloche qui vous
fait des très gros bisous prenez soin de
vous vous et votre famille et vos amis à
tout bon parent voilà les bizkaitar
[Musique]